- [Interviewer] All
right, Glow, welcome back.
- [Glow] Hi.
- [Interviewer] So, you look great.
You look much healthier than
the last time I saw you, right?
- Thank you, yeah, I've
been doing a lot better.
- [Interviewer] So you're no
longer living on the street?
- No, sir, I'm not.
I'm not on Skid Row anymore.
- [Interviewer] You're in an apartment?
- I am, I am.
- That's great.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm in the
area, but I'm not in downtown.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, but
having a roof over your head
is a really nice thing, right?
- That's a fact, that's a fact, yeah.
My health has been doing better.
I got real sick for awhile,
but just symptomatics in my
stomach, and all that stuff,
but I've been cleaned up,
pretty much off of everything.
And weed, except for, and cigarettes.
But yeah, I haven't really been,
I haven't been around it.
- [Interviewer] So you're
last talk was very heavy.
- Very much so, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Very, very,
it was traumatic just
watching you go through it.
- Yeah, it's hard to think about,
and I can't watch the...
- [Interviewer] And how
did that talk affect you?
- Ooh.
I still have, I guess,
flashbacks will be the clearest memories,
I guess, that kind of deal.
- [Interviewer] Of what
you were talking about?
- Right, right, and just yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's hard to talk about.
- Yeah, and for whatever reasons,
like really loud noises,
even cars or just something booming,
just instills a terror in me.
So I'm not sure why,
but I still wake up everyday,
and like I said, grab
the world by the cojones
and say, "Let's go!"
Why not?
(Glow laughing)
- [Interviewer] So a while back
I helped you out a little
bit to get a motor home,
but you've yet to do that, right?
- Not yet, yeah.
- Yes.
- It's still in the works.
Okay, great.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So where
does your life go from here?
Where do you think...
- Well, it's wide open actually.
Like I said, the RV is the goal,
to have a home that you can travel in
but one that it's yours.
And then I might go back to school
just for some psychological
or even art classes.
Just to, you know, maybe, I don't know.
But I'm thinking also of
going up to the woodsy area
or maybe going up to Washington maybe.
I'm not sure yet.
- [Interviewer] The
world, the whole country
is your oyster.
- Kinda!
- You can go where you want.
- Yeah, kinda.
But things have been going really well.
In fact, the gal that I had met
through a mutual friend of
ours was the lady that offered,
with her roommate, offered
to let me move in with them.
So I was grateful for that.
She and I get along real
well, and the other roommate,
we all get along real well.
- [Interviewer] It's nice
to have some friends, right?
- Yeah, yeah, been fortunate.
So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you were
on Skid Row for how long?
- Almost a year, almost a year.
- [Interviewer] What do
you make of Skid Row?
- Oh.
(Glow nervously laughing)
- [Interviewer] How was your
year living here in a tent?
- It was interesting to say the least.
Terrifying to say the least.
An experience like none other,
I don't believe anyone could ever get
unless they were out
here to experience it.
And to this day,
just about everything I
still see and experience
is something I've only ever seen on TV.
So my jaw will still hit the ground.
I tried it out here,
but I'm convinced that when
you don't have a good health,
to be strong out here, it
really makes a difference.
- [Interviewer] I think the
stress of being down here
maybe wears you down.
- Definitely.
- [Interviewer] The filth of Skid Row
maybe boosts your immune system,
but the stress of it...
- Right, breaks everything else down.
- [Interviewer] That's what I've seen.
- Yeah, so, I'm kinda excited
to see what happens next.
And I'm always peeling and looking through
the things on the internet
for RVs in different places.
So, keeping everything positive
and just waiting to see what happens next!
- [Interviewer] Well, it's nice to see
somebody turning the corner and
actually making improvement.
- I'm so grateful.
- [Interviewer] You're one of the few.
- And I'm very grateful.
So grateful and so appreciative
for the people that opened up
their home to me, you know,
and got me off the street
and have been helping me,
and been a support
and have turn into somewhat of a family.
So it's kinda cool.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- [Glow] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
all the traumatic stuff
you went through earlier in your life,
does that still haunt you
and slow you down, or?
- [Glow] I've been having
a lot more reoccurring night
terrors in the last few months,
but there's been a lot going on
also with the holidays
and then family members,
blah, blah, blah.
But I am establishing a doctor
and I'm going to be
going to a psychiatrist,
I believe it is.
- [Interviewer] No, that's great.
- [Glow] Yeah, to try to
talk about some things
'cause it could help,
'cause what I'm doing is
a little more difficult
so I think I'm gonna see,
check it out, can't hurt.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
(Glow laughing)
- [Glow] And if it
doesn't work, well okay,
thank you anyway.
So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Well, I wish you the
best of luck with that.
- [Glow] Thank you, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Just keep improving.
- [Glow] I hope to, yeah, I hope to.
Next goal is the RV,
get ahold of the family,
and just start be happy.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- [Glow] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] The drug use,
what's happening with your drug use?
- The drug use is all but nil.
All but nil.
There are occasions when I will
acquire my drugs of choice,
but they're very small amounts
and they are less than twice a month,
sometimes not even once a month.
But I have my weed because
it helps everything.
And I am trying to quit
smoking cigarettes,
but the whole nervous
thing with the anxiety
still gets in the way.
But I have a doctor
that I'm trying to establish in Hollywood,
and I have an appointment on the 9th,
and they wanna do blood work
and try to start everything.
So, it's taken a while,
but I'm starting to get
things put back in order.
And as soon as I get my
grubby little paws on an RV,
that's a done deal.
Just a done deal.
Didn't even have to be a
big one, new one, nothing.
I'll doctor it up.
(Glow laughing)
But you know.
- [Interviewer] That's great, excellent.
Okay, that's all we need!
- [Glow] All right, cool!
- [Interviewer] It was such a nice change
from the last time!
- [Glow] Oh my gosh, right?